(orchestral music)
- [Sasha] When I'm out on
a wakeboard, it feels free,
like I am able to do what I want.
I'm Sasha Christian,
and I'm Singapore's
number one wakeboarder.
(orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Sasha is Singapore's
first Asian wakeboarding champion.
She started water sports at a young age,
and at 5 years old,
wakeboarding caught her eye.
- [Sasha] I went for my
first wakeboard competition
when I was 11 years old.
It was the Asian
championships held in China,
and I got third that year.
In 2009, it was a big year for me
because I won the Asian championship,
so I was Asian champion for that year.
I now 16 then.
Growing up as a female wakeboarder
most of the people I wakeboarded
with were mostly guys,
you know, my brother included.
But that was actually really good,
because they pushed me really hard,
you know, they didn't cut me any slack.
And so, because of that,
it made me a better wakeboarder as well.
The hardest thing about
wakeboarding would be
pushing yourself when you're afraid.
Pushing through that fear
is one of the hardest things
but also the most rewarding thing.
- [Narrator] Today Sasha trains
Singapore's next generation
of female wakeboarders.
She's eager to push others to succeed
in the same ways she did.
- [Sasha] One of my
biggest goal for this year
is to help to grow the
wakeboard scene in Singapore
and to see the women
keep pushing the standard
on what we have here.
It's important not to
set limits for ourselves.
When there's something
out there you want to do,
or you want to achieve,
don't let anything stand in your way.
There's a way to achieve that.
Don't let anyone else tell you otherwise.
(orchestral music)